cette manifestation cet après midi
devant l'assemblée nationale la
profession méconnue des standiste c'est
à dire les prestataires de foires et de
salons demande d action au gouvernement
il estime que les aides accordées sont
insuffisantes et réclame à la
réouverture des foires pour se faire
entendre des installations funéraire
représentant les différents métiers
touchés par la fermeture des salles ont
été installées devant le palais bourbon
vous le voyez sur ces images pour la
dizaine de manifestants présents sur
place la situation devient dramatique
assez importante défendre le métier de
l'événementiel on est tous à l'arrêt
depuis mars 2020 donc c'est très
compliqué la situation donc voilà on est
là pour se faire entendre et à voir des
perspectives on a perdu 75% notre
chiffre d'affaires on a vraiment besoin
de travailler et
n'ai pas entendu aucune
aucun ministre aucun
aucun retourné depuis 11 mois nous avons
eu les mêmes aides qu'une entreprise qui
a pu reprendre son activité entre les
deux confinement cercle depuis on se
voit on touche 1500 euros par mois et
pour une entreprise c'est carrément
ridicule